holtz et koh lanta est une émission dont
le but est de repousser ses limites les
candidats sont exposés à des conditions
extrêmes dans lesquelles le manque de
sommeil ou le manque de nourriture
peuvent devenir de véritables dangers
mais où s'arrête le jeu robinson
prisonniers aujourd'hui c'est le
magazine le figaro qui révèle que
nombreux sont les candidats qui ont eu
des problèmes de santé après leur
aventure et perte de poids souvent
spectaculaires qui ne sont pas sans
conséquences comme nous l'expliquent le
nutritionniste jean michel cohen au
micro de tpm paix une perte de poids sur
une période de 40 jours et forcément
dangereuses surtout quand il s'agit d'un
jeûne total quand le coeur et privés des
apports en protéines et parfois de
certains minéraux comme le potassium
il peut y avoir un arrêt cardiaque le
risque c'est vraiment la mort subite
mais au-delà de ces épreuves pour le
corps l'émission koh lanta ne laisse pas
non plus à même de les candidats
psychologiquement mais après laventure
comme en témoigne d'orient candidats de
koh lanta les quatre ter il a fallu une
vraie reconstruction
psychologiquement c'est très compliqué
quand je sortais j'avais l'impression
qu'on me regardaient bizarrement je
devenais fou des traumatismes
directement liée à son aventure
je ne supportais plus le lit et j'avais
envie de dormir par terre dans ma
chambre je faisais des cauchemars en me
demandant où j'étais c'était terrifiant
alors malnutrition crise de folie perte
de poids êtes vous choqué par les
révélations sur l'après koh lanta alors
là là je vous le dis ça ça fait couler
beaucoup d'encre alors vous avez vu que
j'avais jean michel cohen mon ami du tri
sioniste qui est exceptionnel et il est
très très fort jacques cohen louis jean
michel cohen en plus c'est le seul gars
il est nutritionniste mais ils mangent
bien tu vois plus pressé le sugar il y
bien tu verras son bureau mon lui dit tu
vas pas manger minutes à des pizzas dans
les points négatifs
jean michel cohen c'est jean-michel
côtelettes le gars c'est un truc de fou
et que deuxièmement voilà mais au moins
il met en confiance moi
alors est ce que vous êtes choqués je
vais démarrer par ça qui fait son grand
retour benhaim nom alors je ne suis pas
choqué je ne suis même pas étonné c'est
à dire pourquoi on découvre ce que l'on
voit à l'antenne c'est à dire des gardes
et des garçons et des filles qui au bout
de 40 jeux quand on les voit d'ailleurs
quand il se met face au miroir
ils sont physiquement décharné on le
voit qu'ils ont péri jeudi des dizaines
de kilos hang on a fait en 40 jours donc
on imaginer dit évidemment que le corps
morfle et que de toute façon le corps va
le faire payer par la suite après donc
non pas de l'armoire quand on me dira
après coup j'ai saisi il ya eu un effet
rebond il ya eu un effet compliqué et
morales juste peut dire un truc marrant
hyper important parce que valérie vous
vous sentez le truc là jeu sérieux deux
minutes
vraiment il faut écouter son corps il ya
toujours un gars qui te dit il se prend
pour un grand médecin et tulipe schéma
les poules écoute s'il faut vraiment que
tu lèves le pied il faut que tu écoute
ton corps non mais vrai bon là je te le
dis oui mais des imams et moralement
évidemment ils sont sur une île a priori
désert qui sont quoi une quarantaine
avec l'équipe technique - bar ils sont
immergés dans un jeu où il ya évidemment
des les uns qui sont montés contre les
autres et c'est notre happé par ce truc
là qui d'ailleurs nourri un peu une
paranoïa puisque je parle derrière mon
dos ou d'augmenter et y dorment la nuit
par terre et a donc quand tu reviens
dans une vie un peu dit civilisé même si
c'est la stylisation là bas aussi bas
tout d'un coup tu te évidemment que tu
te dis bah qu'est ce qui m'arrive est
comme union dormir par terre je l'avais
des groupes hisser sur scène alors qu'on
pensait qui faillit bonvoisin vous êtes
choqués je suis choqué je suis surprise
et de l'île choquer mais non mais c'est
pas moi qui parle ce sont des médecins
des médecins qui ont dit qu'ils vont
dire ils ont pu vouloir de faire de
fernand joueurs sont leurs mots déjà il
y en avait en 2017 qui avait alerté sur
les dangers en disant qu'il avait avec
un an faisant un tel jeunes des risques
cardiaques mortels d'ostéoporose pour
les femmes se dr ya aussi des prises de
poids obésité boulimie regardez par
exemple les stocks avaient pris 22 kilos
en six mois
clémentine qu'elle ait perdu tous ses
cheveux donc la presse survie est tout
aussi brutal pour le métabolisme et pour
l'organisme donc je suis absolument
choquée et surprise regarder ou alors
ils regardent la place et il a fait
kolontar noir
moi je pense quand on fait une émission
d'aventuré il faut assumer si les
candidats ne permet pas de poids que
l'on dirait que c'est truqué et nous on
a interrogé pas mal d'aventuriers ce
qu'on a fait un doc sur koh lanta pas
mal j'ai toujours un coup d'avancé mais
c'est vrai ils disent tous que oui c'est
une vraie mission d' aventure ça qui a
pas à manger c'est la galère et s'est en
revanche dit qui est un problème de
santé un peu sérieux sur le tournage il
ya une équipe médicale donc donc c'est
normal qu'ils perdent un peu de poids
faux faux faux faux pas être choqué on a
un extrait de pascal brisset très dur
pour lui en reste à lire à conques
l'enfer de l'après koh lanta et il a eut
perdu énormément de points a perdu du
poids et pas seulement il dit qu'il
avait des problèmes psychologiques des
troubles du sommeil des doubles
dédoublement de la personnalité donc
c'était un peu chaud pour lui car je
vous dis quand vous avez dormi et de
combien septans la koh lanta ce cas car
en 42 jours
mais moi je dis il faut le faire en
quatre heures ça c'est pas des vrais
c'est maintenant c'est des fausses elles
ont été j'ai pour au fait parce que
quand je fais deux fois koh lanta là bas
j'y ai laissé beaucoup de pros j'avais
des dents en compte mon jeune ami es tu
manges n'importe quoi moi
personnellement je mangeais tout ce qui
vous pouvez en sus et du bois des boues
bâton sur après avec une dentition très
très compliqué car les conditions
extrêmes de koh lanta peuvent avoir de
lourdes conséquences pour les
aventuriers après le jeu je suis rentré
qu'une grosse infection j'y rentre avec
plein de problèmes d'intestins j'ai fait
une nuit en urgence parce que j'avais
comme un infarctus de l'intestin
vous montrez vos morphée j'ai perdu 18
kilos en 40 jours on ne peut pas dire
que koh lanta c'est du pipeau et tu te
dire que tu te penches air pur comme ça
dans les parties je peux dire que c'est
mal c'est en fait moi je trouve que ce
qui serait intéressant c'était d'avoir
un temps d'adaptation avant et après je
comprends pas pourquoi quand ils
rentrent ils rendent directement chez
eux mais peut-être voulu mettre dans une
cabane au fond du jardin
tabac info service ou cabrel mais l
appât est là il serait beaucoup mieux je
pense sinon alors isabelle faut mieux la
faire parler tout de suite après 21
heures avait terminé sa wii alors déjà
donné vous tu étais plus après
l'audition honnêtement s'il n'y avait
pas un bataillon de médecins et tout
l'émission était arrêté depuis longtemps
il ya eu quelques accidents de parcours
mais c'est d'ailleurs toujours le
téléspectateur qui demandait ce que ça
reparte et ce alors même que tout le
monde se posait des questions maintenant
je suis désolé il ya vraiment une équipe
qui les suit le monsieur quelle nulle
autre jour là laurent tu nous racontes
il est suivi par un psychologue après
j'ai eu 10 allemands excusez moi mais
d'un bon régime
quand vous quand vous faites un régime
vous savez tous que vous vous risquez de
remanger de roba frais après et de
rappeler sans ceinture que c'est la
femme chat ce qu'on appelle le de nous
mais moi c'est pas ça c'est quand ils
vont sur une épreuve de confort et qui
bafouent dans l'épreuve de concerts qui
sont malades le land à ses horizons ne
devrait pas les îles samoa son effet le
plus contrôlé ras le cul de sa tête j'en
ai pas de confort
ils se gavent de caprice des dieux et
après moi j'en ai marre
voilà rien d'autre qu'à pas tant les
potes kauffer moi j'aime les bons scores
chez moi j'ai guirado là je peux te dire
que ça moi j'ai perdu 10 kg à pékin
express bah oui mais c'est sûr pékin
express va oui bah oui merci c'était
quand même c'est bien de le rappeler
vous l'avez fait non mais oui moi ça ce
soir bonsoir satine bon ça at il alors
c'est vrai son vrai prénom c'est pas une
ombre with your états unis j'adore
satine ça revient donc je vais dire que
sincèrement je trouve ça terrible dans
le sens où c'est trop extrêmes alors je
n'avais pas du tout qui avait une équipe
médicale sur le tournage chaud mais je
trouve ça tellement trop extrêmes et
comme l'a dit je sais plus qui mais il
faudrait vraiment un temps d'adaptation
est un vieux mais c'est la réalité c'est
tellement brutale et oui logiquement
c'est pas possible
vous appelez ça team comment c'est une
vallée avec un double à ces mots parce
que je me dis satine il faut avoir après
un long extrait derrière tu appelles
satine boukobza t'appelle à salut
bonjour satine benchetrit
je suis le cousin d'un marvin martin du
colza
alors qui peut parler là parce que
j'avais beaucoup de gens qui levait la
main mais pour dire des choses
intéressantes oui elle a raison de dire
qu'effectivement il ya évidemment une
équipe médicale il ya aussi une psy qui
va les suivre après parce que c'est la
presse qui est très important c'est
d'abord les familles ne comprennent pas
la douleur qu'ils ont vécu ou ce qu'ils
ont traversé et lorsque j'ai appris
c'est qu'au moment de certaines épreuves
ont leur prépa pour les plus faibles du
lait avec
allez vous savez c'est vrai quoi viser
un shoot de glucides et oui et donc ils
mangent sur koh lanta nous attend juste
une épreuve quand ils sont vraiment trop
hélas si vous êtes en train de dire non
non c'est vrai c'est officiel c'est
officiel et c'est eux qui le disent un
cocktail de banane avec du lait ouais
c'est pour éviter qu'il n'y ait rien non
mais les mecs locaux le principe de koh
lanta si tu manges pas ça commence à
manger dans koh lanta c'est comme s'ils
se connaissaient ah ah ah je sais pas
avoir pété dans touche pas à mon poste
je dis voilà comics n importe quoi la
cedh escalade de l'horreur oui cécile
infirmier urgentiste qui est là sur
l'île
voilà se dit à ce moment là ils ont
besoin parce qu'ils ont vraiment trop de
carences et que sa viande dangereux ils
peuvent leur donner ce fameux cette
fameuse mix10 la voir même de la viande
je la prendrai jamais sa valeur c'est
parce que c'est les protéines voiture
c'est vrai à bord de l'appareil un jour
même je sais pas si vous connaissez si
l'on fait un complet pression sur koh
lanta ça c'est un poisson avec des
frites l'attestera tout ça une salade de
tomates s'est enfin qui n'ont rien
n'arrivait même pas à l'épreuve de
confort le gars il est arrivé et a même
à gagnera netsuke somalie le ramener a
été comme ça frère d une kenya truc
frères ils sont démantelés fricassée
boulin briques à leur faut savoir que
tous les candidats avant de partir là
bas sont choyés 1200 il fonde et des
examens du coeur a donc effectivement il
ya un risque
tout ya toujours un risque mais sûre et
que la production va et on va les
défendre ils sont excessivement exigeant
et la santé physique et mentale des
candidats avant de partir puis prennent
je pense le minimum de risques et a
toujours un risque et ça lui prenait
venir sur 15 heures maintenant
sa taille est oui genre avant de partir
ils sont soutenus mais une fois qu'ils
sont rentrés sur ses quais ya une
absence en fait
est ce qu'une fois qu'ils sont rentrés
chez eux mais il ya quelqu'un sais pas
je t'aime non mais ça dans une fois
qu'ils sont chez eux je peux te dire
qu'ils sont à l'abandon tu crois
vraiment que la production est pour
aller taper à leur porte
ils en ont rien à carrer et c'est ce que
je veux dire c'est l'arrière
petite-fille blu ray mc ce de concert
william saurin
juste un psychologue scolaire ce que je
trouverais regrettable mais qui épanouit
diététicien ou de nutritionnistes sévère
cette année je trouve qu'on a vu des
gens au stade des martyrs s'agit des
téléspectateurs j'ai des chiffres qui
tombent toutes les mines on a beau à
vendredi
l'eia récation couscous dû être dans
quelques minutes pas non plus faire tout
n'importe quoi oui alors que j'étais
voulait cette année à l'antenne qui
avait des gens véritablement anneaux
réclame aussi et d'areva et je trouvais
que c'était pas beau générale qui a eu
deux familles à mes filles et deux
garçons qui étaient vraiment comme ça
toutefois ce casque est quand même
bonsoir ski c'est quand même fou c'est
que chaque année j'ai l'impression
depuis que le programme de téléréalité
existe chaque fois le problème des
psychologues
non mon époque on parlait en et patrie
et ça nous aurait bien aidé
et là on a toujours ce petit problème de
suivi est apparemment mais depuis des
années depuis 20 ans maintenant ça
avance toujours elle suivait un mec sans
rigoler c'est vrai non mais c'est vrai
j'ai vu c'est un candidat d'un jeu on a
eu des mots tus
il ya une histoire
vous savez que brice il a pas fait caca
pendant 21 jours
c'est grave la comex upton quoi il n'a
pas fait caca pour ne pas mettre la
jours mais c'est dramatique c'est
extrêmement dangereux aussi possible
mais évidemment c'est ce qu'il a dit
évidemment que c'est possible quand vous
n'êtes pas que oui aux philippines
on est resté quasiment un mois aux
philippines est jeune et j'ai vu je fais
pipi mais sur site une fermette
mais le reste rien s'est pas rendu
compte
c'est dingue de voir parce que demain il
va avoir des titres 1 partout sur tous
les abonnements et les boeufs ça c'est
intéressant ça non mais je suis très
grave ce que vous vivez ce qu'elle était
en train de faire du buzz là on les
presse ça reste une minorité en
vingt-et-une saison de koh lanta est le
plus 350 candidats oui il y en a
certains qui ont des problèmes on a vu
laurent mais ce trait etc qui avait
aucun problème
c'est une super expérience pour eux est
vraiment des cas d'anorexie comme ça et
de dédoublement de personnalité c'est
des cas isolés
parmi elles peuvent pas une émission qui
si vous seriez prêt à faire koh lanta
vraiment j'adore mes capacités
j'adore déjà vous voyez rien plus rien
rien mais est-ce que vous pensez que
vous pouvez tenir voix largement jean
pascal était impossible voilà benhaim
absolument pas le répéter il reste
l'accès impossible de dormir par terre
j'ai mal au dos sinon les insectes tout
ça j'ai peur enfin danxia rien que la
paix est impossible
aïssa impôts si les araignées les
inserts type c'est pour ça oui mais les
insectes le côté mouillé tu admires sur
ce match avoue c'est le côté moulineaux
un bon mois pour perdu quand j'ai
rejoint dans mes frères toi la baston
pourquoi ya pas de magasin faire y'a pas
d'uv y'a pas toi y'a pas de blanchiment
dans les foules celui-là non mais
pourquoi moi j'irai pour être conseiller
de l'équipe c'est à dire au corps de la
mère avec les palmiers et rien d'autre
mais les épreuves jamais pour rien
[ __ ] oui mais pour suivre ma vie
depuis 40 ans et isabelle et bien moi en
résistance contre moins ce que vous
dites et je l'éprouvé oui sans aucun
temps la gueule que j'aurai je peut
infliger ça à personnage le seul truc
alors donc ne vous endormez pas sur le
poteau je pense qu'au niveau de la
survie de l'instinct et où je m'en
sortirai mais psychologiquement
j'arrivais rappaz isolement et tout mon
humeur varie en fonction de la
nourriture si je ne mange pas je dois
être très viril avoir même détestable
allemand jamais je colle à non je mange
tout le temps j'adore manger si je ne
mange match une mauvaise humeur pourrait
que c'est une interview pour celle-ci
croit qu'elle est en fin d'interview
dans cette habite dans un autre ce taux
il y aura avec thierry demaizière
[Musique]
tiffany bon voisin qui a déclaré cette
semaine si je ne mange pas je deviens
ira s'il en est in quelles ont été les
conséquences
c'est vrai dans un instant votre
portrait de la semaine
[Musique]
[Rires]